j'ai fait 2 secondes de
première tu fais toutes les classes
comme ça
en je sais pas si si ça continue la
terminage je la feraai deux fois
aussi moi je voulais redoubler mais
c'était le redoublement qui n'était pas
jugé nécessaire ah d'accord c'était toi
qui j'ai oui je voulais redoubler parce
que je je savais qu'en fin de compte
j'aurais peut-être pu passer dans une
classe supérieure mais en fin de compte
ils n'ont pas voulu j'étais déjà
certainement trop vieille je pensais je
pensais passer en terminal facile ouais
bon parce que je voyais que qu'à travers
la CLA j'étais pas mauvais puis bon ben
on m'a dit tu redoues c'était gros choc
sur mon bulletin j'ai reçu et en bas il
y avait un petit mot c'était marqué que
je redoublé quoi
réaction
benah j'avais peur parce que je savais
pas dans quelle classe que j'allais
tomber et tout la deuxiè seconde j'ai
encore moins travaillé que la
première la première seconde alors bon
ça moi je pense ça ne m'a absolument
servi à rien j'ai pris ça comme étant
une sanction
de toute façon maintenant je pense
qu'ils ont eu raison de me sanctionner
mais ils auraient pas dû me sanctionner
de cette façon là je pense je suis
parvenu à avoir des not correcte parce
que parce que je
redoublais c'est tout mais non je pense
pas que ça soit enfin pour moi ça pe été
profitable le redoublement n'est pas une
solution en soi pour certains élèves
c'est une bonne solution pour d'autres
elle peut être très mauvaise je crois
que tout dépend de la façon dont l'élève
réagit face à cette situation de
redoublement il y a des élèves qui
demandent le redoublement h parce qu'il
ils en sentent le le besoin moi je l'ai
vraiment senti comme comme quelque chose
de très très positif parce que j'ai pris
confiance en moi et puis et puis bon ben
c'est pas le bagne de redoubler je veux
dire on au début c'était c'était triste
parce qu'on se dit mais j'ai j'ai loupé
quelque chose et en fait non on apprend
plus par rapport à soi par rapport aux
autres par rapport au boulot en décembre
j'ai demandé le redoublement j'ai parlé
avec mes profs tout ça on s'est mis
d'accord puis j'ai redoublé et ta deè
seconde ça a été mieux ma première anée
3e j'ai mal travaillé tout on a tout le
temps riggoler donc cé obligatoire que
je redouble parce que comme moi je
voulais je voulais tellement venir en
seconde pour continuer ben j'ai dit
ouais je redouve ma trè et tout il y a
pas de problème que la proposition de
doublement soit une demande des familles
un souhait de l'élève ce qui est cas de
figure très rare ou un une proposition
de de conseil de classe je pars de
l'idée que il n'est pas certain que le
fait de recommencer exactement la même
chose l'année qui suit soit
immédiatement bénéfique et que je serais
peut-être plus favorable au forcing pour
le passage dans la classe supérieure en
assumant tous les risques de ce que je
peux dire c'est-à-dire le décrochage
encore plus complet de l'élève si c'est
pour le lui refaire faire dans les mêmes
forme parlons par image pour lui
resservir la même soupe aussi salée euh
il a boira pas plus le début de l'année
de doublement c'est dramatique je peux
vous le dire c'est c'est complètement
dramatique parce que mon disons que
j'avais des on était on sentait plus
vieux des gens sortai de seconde pour
arriver en premiè alors que nous on
avait fait déjà une seconde une première
et encore une première on se sentait
comment dire supérieur alors que sur le
papier on était au même niveau donc il y
a peut-être même un peu de sentiment de
de frustration en plus quand on arrive à
l'école le premier jour de la rentrée
quand on arrive dans la classe déjà sur
les listes on a notre nom souligné
puisqu'on est redoublant et on a
l'impression que que les autres élèves
bon ben on a une étiquette redoublant et
on a l'impression dans la classe d'être
un intru d'être d'être quelqu'un de pas
normal on essaie désormais d'envisager
le doublement uniquement sous un jour
positif et c'est donc un élève qui a
acquis suffisamment de maturité pour
dépasser ses problèmes personnels et
pour au plan scolaire des connaissances
qu'il n'a pas pu acquérir en raison de
difficultés très particulières et très
personnelles l'année précédente c'est ça
un doublement réussi à mon
[Musique]
avis